si le monument de paris le plus connu
aussi connu que la tour eiffel il est
vrai que l'arc de triomphe trône je
devrais dire triomphe tout au bout de la
perspective unique au monde des champs
elysées monument entrer dans la
mythologie vous savez bien que les
marchands de bronze du monde entier en
fabrique que chaque année des millions
d'exemplaires
est ce que vous savez que cet acte de
trion en fait n'a jamais été terminée et
qu'il aurait dû être surmonté de
gigantesques groupe de chevaux ce que
vous savez en revanche c'est qu'il a été
voulue bien entendu par napoléon qu'il
avait fait dresser à la gloire de ses
armées alors triomphante
ensuite la chance des armées
napoléoniennes à tourner mais depuis 170
ans l'arc de triomphe reste tout de même
le coeur de la france etc
ce témoin privilégié de l'histoire de
france qu en savoir plus vous fait
découvrir maintenant
[Musique]
du haut de ses 50 m l'arc de triomphe de
l'étoile domina plus célèbre est sans
doute la plus belle perspective urbaine
du monde
c'est en 1806 que napoléon fidèles à
l'antique tradition des empereurs
romains décide de faire élever à sa
gloire et à la gloire de ces armes est
un gigantesque arc de triomphe sur l'un
de ses piliers ont soit rude sculptera à
la demande monsieur pierre n'ont pas la
marseillaise comme chacun le croit mais
très exactement le départ des
volontaires de combien d'événements
prestigieux sera-t-il ainsi le témoin le
14 juillet 1919 les troupes de la
victoire des fils sous l'arc de triomphe
on n'a pas vu sans doute cérémonie plus
émouvantes
depuis ce jour de décembre 1840 où les
cendres de napoléon avait suivi le même
chemin
escorté par un impressionnant cortège ou
peut-être depuis la nuit du 31 mai 1885
durant laquelle la dépouille de victor
hugo est exposée sous l'arc drapé d'un
immense crêpe noir
le 11 novembre 1920 le soldat inconnu
commence sa veille au pied du monument
et tous les présidents de la république
se doivent de lui rendre régulièrement
hommage
albert lebrun vincent auriol rené coty
le général de gaulle georges pompidou
hommage aussi du monde entier hirohito
en 1921
fouad premier georges 6 la reine juliana
elizabeth 2 eisenhower et nikita
khrouchtchev le chancelier adenauer le
président john kennedy et richard nixon
winston churchill le 7 ou 1919
charles godefroy gagne le pari le plus
fou à ses sous l'arc avec un aéroplane
c'est que l'arc de triomphe est aussi un
symbole pour tous les sportifs et plus
particulièrement pour les coureurs du
tour de france 1976 lancer dans leur
dernier sprint sur les champs elysées en
d'autres temps moins insouciant l'ennemi
fêtait à l'arc de triomphe une de nos
plus humiliantes défaites dont le
maréchal leclerc devait bientôt nous
faire oublier l'amertume
on manifeste à l'arc de triomphe en
février 1934 aussi bien qu'en 1956
tout début de la guerre d'algérie où
rené pleven est violemment prise à
partie par la foule des émeutiers
mai 68
tenaillés entre ses ambitions
révolutionnaires et sa soif d'ordre et
de paix sociale
c'est la france de toujours qui
s'affrontent ici avant de se réconcilier
à l'ombre du glorieux au menu morts
[Musique]